now if you're really trying to talk
about solving climate change then you
got to think globally
we've been mostly talking about america
the liberal democracies the west
we have to adjust the lens to the big
picture global view as well
now we have a lot of these technologies
are inexorable and that they could scale
globally
it turns out there's other inexorables
at the global level too there's mega
trends that are
beyond tech that are quite fortuitous
they're largely
positive developments that could help us
solve
a lot of these challenges too
particularly climate change
one of them is burgeoning capital we
have the technologies but do we have the
capital to transition our entire energy
system
to transition the economy to sustainable
everything
well it's about a hundred trillion
dollars in capital markets sloshing
around right now it's all looking for
productive investments
and it's actually not getting the kind
of returns it wants i think the super
tanker of global finance is going to
move this decade and there's signs that
it's happening
much faster than people think another
inexorable is
chinese superpowers china has now
at the end of their 30-year run become
truly
a global super power and we need them
china
can actually move and act in ways that
the liberal democracies as
of now can't we're still debating in
america whether climate change is real
and china is just moving huge amounts of
assets
also the chinese model is much more
relevant to the developing world
they pulled 800 million peasants out of
the poverty into cities in the last 30
years
and that's something that has to happen
around the world which brings up total
urbanization
another inexorable in this last decade
the world tipped
past 50 percent of the world now in
cities it's about 55
now but it's heading to 80 percent by
2050.
this is essentially a good tendency for
the planet it lowers the human footprint
it brings many other positive
developments like empowering women
which lowers the number of children and
which essentially reduces population
pressures
another global inexorable is middle
class majorities
just in the last few years the world
crossed another milestone
in which we have now 50 of the people on
the planet are
middle class 3.6 billion
people now this is considered middle
class in a global context these are
people who can afford maybe something
like a refrigerator or a motorbike or
have some mild security
unlike people who are really destitute
or poor
now this is not what we think of in the
west
as the middle class those would be
considered more almost rich people
in a global context now middle class
majorities in a global context
is a good thing middle class people
spend almost everything they make back
into the economy
driving economic growth middle-class
people tend to be a huge stabilizing
force
in society they demand good government
they're trying to get good
learning and education things that are
good for
everybody in the long haul by 2030
it's estimated that the world will add
another 1.7
billion middle-class people to their
ranks this again is
global middle-class people to their
ranks we're going to have
well over 5 billion people
who are considered in the global middle
class
going forward beyond that point